Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our session.
We're going to go
ahead and get started.
Please go ahead and find a seat.
We're going to be spending much
of our hour in small groups.
And that's why the tables
have numbers on them.
So we have a pretty
packed hour ahead of us.
So a key challenge
for the three of us
that are presenting this session
is to stick to our script,
and to manage, not only
our time, but your time.
So please note that the
session is being recorded.
And that's why we're
using the microphones
even though we don't really need
them for a room of this size.
So we're very
excited that you've
joined us to learn a
little bit about what's
happening beyond Harvard.
I'm going to kick us off with
introductions and a session
outline.
Allison is going to lead the
small group analysis of models
from other colleges
and universities.
I'll facilitate the reports
back from each small group.
And then Kris will provide
some concluding remarks.
First, some introductions.
Kris Markman is Director
of Digital Learning
and User Experience at
the Harvard Library.
In addition to the details
in the conference program,
I wanted to mention her
teaching experiences
at the University of Memphis and
the University of Texas-Austin.
Allison Pingree is Director
of Professional Pedagogy
at the Harvard Kennedy School.
She has provided pedagogical
support to faculty
there for several years.
Her connections across
the national POD network
were essential for our
preparation for this session.
I'm Anu Vedantham.
I'm the Director of Learning
and Teaching Services
for the FAS Libraries.
I joined Harvard a year ago.
And my work for a decade each at
the University of Pennsylvania
and Stockton University have
informed my contributions
to this session.
So the HILT Conference explores
many exciting activities
across the Harvard landscape.
Our session looks
outside Harvard,
which is a very big place.
And trying to summarize it in
an hour will be interesting.
So we examine the
question, how do
other universities and colleges
handle teaching evaluations?
We noted that the instruments
in use across the nation
can be very blunt, or they
can be overly complex.
Some practices include homegrown
surveys, national instruments
such as the IDEA, focus groups,
interviews, peer observation,
faculty self-evaluation,
inter-faculty sharing,
narrative analysis, and
student-led crowdsourcing.
So what are some good
practices happening elsewhere
that could inform our work here?
I'll start by noting that the
topic of teaching evaluations
is universally
fraught with anxiety.
So we corresponded with
colleagues at several levels
in a variety of institutions.
In our conversations
we heard frustration.
We heard nervousness
about numbers.
And several
institutions discussed
how they have recently changed
their measurement instruments.
So evaluations of
teaching are not static.
And institutions
continuously review
and adjust the
instruments that they use,
and also how they
interpret the results.
What you are hearing today is
an analysis for September 2017.
And next year there
will be changes ahead.
So just to say that this
is as a moment in time.
In addition to the
formative impact where
teaching evaluations data
informs changes in teaching
practice, we also heard
about summative consequences
for re-appointment, for
tenure, and for promotion.
We also heard about the
consequences of evaluated data
for students making course
selection decisions.
And this was a topic that
caused anxiety and controversy,
and one where the
perspectives of faculty,
academic administrators, and
students were pretty divergent.
We heard concerns about who
has access to what data at what
time, and how
misunderstanding of data
can really lead to
some bad decisions.
So we'll start by
noting that there
is a vast amount of
literature in the education
field on this topic.
There is debate about the
validity, the utility,
and the advisability of various
teaching evaluation mechanisms
that are used for
summative purposes.
The end-of-course student
ratings of instruction
are especially a
point of contention.
We will not engage explicitly
with this literature,
because we do not have the
time to do it justice here.
We welcome you to
follow up with us
if this topic is of interest.
And we can provide some
annotated bibliographies.
Because there
really is a lot that
has been written on the topic.
Today, instead, we
are going to ask
you to engage in close reading
of a few selected instruments.
We're not endorsing
these instruments.
We offer them to
you as raw material
for your own reflection.
These are examples and artifacts
that may inform our work here
at Harvard.
A few common questions did
emerge from our conversations
with colleagues of the
different institutions.
Who gets to see the data?
Do administrators see that data?
Do they compare numbers across
faculty, across disciplines,
and across institutions?
Do students get to analyze
the data to make course choice
decisions?
And how do stakeholders
express frustration
with the instruments?
So just some questions
to keep in mind.
I'm going to hand
it over to Allison
who's going to guide us
through our small group
analysis of specific
instruments.
Great.
Thank you, Anu.
Wonderful to see you all.
At your tables, you have
two sets of documents.
You have a worksheet
in a paper clip.
If you'll take that paper
clip off and pass around
the worksheets to
everyone, one copy
for each person at the table.
As you can see from
that worksheet,
we're going to be spending
time looking closely, as Anu
mentioned, at some artifacts.
Each table has a
different institution
from whose collection
of materials
we have shared with
you a few bits of--
a few artifacts related
to evaluation of teaching
for summative purposes.
So clarification
about our focus here.
We're not diving into
teaching evaluation
for formative purposes.
This is higher stakes, decisions
about promotion and tenure,
student course selection.
There's a lot to be said
about formative feedback.
That's not our focus.
What we're going to invite you
to do in a moment is to open
the envelope that's
at your table,
and to take a look at-- before
you do, look with me at the--
I shouldn't have said that.
That's just baiting you.
So looking at the
worksheet, you'll
see there are four
questions there
for individual reflection.
So we're going to ask you
to take five minutes each.
Take five minutes to look
at what's in the envelope.
And think about those
four questions, about--
with this artifact,
with this instrument
or with this approach,
what kind of information,
what kind of data, from whom,
is this approach engaging?
What kinds of things does
this model or approach
assume that good
teaching looks like?
What kinds of institutional
values or assumptions
are being made here?
And what questions does
this model or approach
raise for you?
Then, in groups, you'll
talk about, in general,
the pros and cons of
this instrument or model.
Please appoint a note
taker and a reporter,
so that when we have
our lightning round
report-outs of two
minutes each, someone
is prepared to stand
up and say, here's
what we saw as the pros and
cons of this model or approach.
As each table is talking
about their approach or model,
Kris will be showing those
models on the document camera
up on the screen.
We also have put together the
complete collection of models
as a PDF at a Bitly link.
And that way all
of you have access
to all the materials that
we got for this session,
rather than making copies
of every instrument
for every person to look at.
Not a good use of paper.
So essentially your task now
is five minutes of individual
reading, and
thinking, and writing,
15 minutes of
discussion at table
to prepare for
two-minute report-outs
on the questions
on the worksheet.
Any questions from
you at this point?
You'll see in your envelopes
what your objects of study are.
Go ahead and open.
On your marks, get set, go.
OK.
Because time is
tight, we're going
to encourage you as
provisionally as you've
been able to glance
at the documents
and start to make
sense of them--
there's a lot more you could
do with that individually.
But let's encourage you, now, to
start to talk as a group about,
in general, what
did you notice here?
What are the things
that you think
are particularly strong or
useful about this approach?
What are the things
that you think
are drawbacks, or questions,
puzzlements that you have?
So kind of pro-con.
And again, if you'll
appoint someone
to take notes and be
prepared to report out,
you can see the strengths and
drawbacks area of the worksheet
now to be focusing on.
So go ahead and start
talking as a group.
We're going to wrap up
the group conversations.
Finish whatever
thought you're on.
Please raise your hand if you
are the designated reporter.
You're going to be
prepared to speak.
Just raise your hand so we
make sure everybody knows
what's happening.
Who's going to
report out over here?
Over here?
Yeah.
Got it.
Great.
We are so eager to hear what
you guys have come up with.
And I'm sure you're eager to
hear about the other tables
and models.
As I said, all of the models
are available on the Bitly link
that we've projected,
and we'll project again.
For the time that we'll be
analyzing a specific model,
Kris is going to show a portion
of it on the document camera.
But there's a lot
more information
that we won't be able
to show at a glance.
So you'll be able to look
at that later in the Bitly.
OK, lightning round.
I'm going to be timing.
Anu is going to be facilitating.
So I'm going to
come table to table.
Two minutes per table.
So we're going to
go ahead and start.
We have a very strict timeline.
So in addition to
managing my own time,
I get to manage yours.
So we're going to start
with table one, which
is in the far back.
As we take on each instrument,
Kris will pull the instrument
up on the document camera.
And just to note that you have
full access to all of them
later, in case you
really want to geek out
on different types of surveys.
Allison is going
to use an iPhone
timer set at two minutes.
So when it makes a loud sound,
then that is time to wrap up.
Our first model is
Stanford University,
table one in the far back.
Tamara is our spokesperson.
OK, so the first
thing to know on this
is that the first question is
a customizable question based
on learning goals.
And we both thought
that this is fantastic.
It emphasizes what
the instructor
thinks is most important.
And it indicates a strong
commitment to student learning.
And that commitment
to student learning
is echoed in multiple questions.
However, we also felt that there
are some potential drawbacks
to both starting with
the learning goals
and having this be
open-ended, in that,
what if the learning goals
aren't well designed?
What if an instructor
puts in learning
goals that are just easy to
reach for the sake of getting
good feedback?
So we had a lot of questions
about how that actually works.
We think it's fantastic
that this survey has a lot
of customizable questions,
realizing that there's not just
one-size-fits-all for
teaching and learning.
And it also seemed
like the interface
would be easy to use on the
side of the faculty member who
needs to do that customizing.
There are a number of
formative questions
that will give the instructor
some feedback about how
they can improve their course.
But on that note, we
thought that there
could be more specific
open-ended questions about ways
to improve.
We noted that there
was no feedback
about individual instructors.
Let's see.
There were some kind of--
there was clearly an emphasis
on online education here.
And that there is
a question about,
what percentage of the class
meetings do you attend online?
But we thought
that question could
be challenging to interpret.
And we would appreciate a
question about prior knowledge.
What did students
bring into the class?
And also how did this motivate
them to take further courses
in this discipline?
Thank you, table one.
You've set a very good model
for the other tables to follow.
Table two had North
Carolina State.
Please just share
your name, also, just
before you give your wrap-up.
OK.
Hi, my name is David Jennings.
And yeah, like you said, we
had North Carolina State.
And this is a very comprehensive
and prescriptive method
of evaluation,
that we thought may
be the case because it
is a state school and not
a private school.
But some strengths of it were
that it was comprehensive,
like I said.
There's opportunities
for students to rate,
peers to rate, instructors
to discuss and self-rate
themselves.
And also administrators to give
a final review of a portfolio.
So that 360 approach
we thought was good.
There's evaluation of the
syllabus by both students
and peers.
And they seem to be very
interested in the goals
and objectives of the syllabus.
There was some vague terms.
Like, they used the word
"appropriate" a lot.
I think it's on the next page.
And so they never
really operationalized
the term, appropriate.
So we saw some room for maybe
some political interference
in some of this process.
We also thought that,
well it's a pro that it
is prescriptive
and measurable, it
may be too rigid for
academic freedom.
And so we maybe
had some concerns
about how this would work at
a liberal arts institution.
So some things that we
could adopt, possibly.
We liked the idea of
syllabus standards
at the department level.
We also liked the
idea of peer review
among the department of goals
and objectives in the syllabus,
and potentially a peer review
committee as well as some--
even cross-departmental
collaboration.
Like people who are maybe
in a different school
but are teaching a
similar discipline.
There's our timer.
But I think we've covered a lot.
And this particular
document was also very long.
So your table gets
extra credit for having
to do a lot of reading.
Our third table is table
three, taking on the University
of Pennsylvania.
And if the person
speaking could quickly
give their name and start.
Hi, I'm Julia King.
This was an interesting one.
Because if you
flip the page over,
the way the students saw
the rankings of a course
was almost like
RateMyProfessors.com
when they're picking
their courses.
And these numbers--
we're not sure
exactly how, but they
came from the survey that
was on the other side.
We thought the
strengths were that it
would take very little time
to fill out the survey.
There's no survey
fatigue, because it
was very simple to answer.
This could be a
strength or a weakness.
The first question was asking
the quality of the course.
So it kind of gave
someone an opportunity
to just instinctively
choose what they thought
the quality was right
off the bat without being
asked some further questions.
A few interesting
things about this one
is that, in the
description it says
that questions 6 through
10 were recently added.
And the survey used to be just
one, two, three, four, five,
and then 10, 11.
And the original survey
was very much based
on quality, difficulty, and
if you like the professor.
And then the second
set of questions
that were added were much
more about critical thinking,
and what you thought you
gained from the class,
did it help you.
And we thought those
questions were interesting.
Because it kind of informed what
they meant the other questions
to ask, but they asked
them more specifically.
Let me look at my notes.
There was a comment that it
looks like a marketing tool
to put this on a
website for students,
instead of being something
that actually professors could
use to improve their course.
Because they didn't have any
direct feedback or comments
from the students
on how to do that.
Perfect timing.
Thank you so much.
I think of all the
different tables,
this is the one
that has quite a lot
of student-created
representations of the data
that's collected.
Our fourth table took on
the University of Notre Dame
over there.
Please introduce yourself.
My name's Annika.
And so these other
schools, they've
been looking at
the specific survey
instrument that was used.
This is kind of how professors
are evaluated overall
for their teaching
in consideration
for tenure and advancement.
And so we liked that they
took a balanced approach.
So feedback from students.
You can see this course
instructor feedback.
We didn't have that instrument.
But we think that's kind of a
standardized survey of student
perceptions.
And that's balanced with
feedback from peers.
Because they acknowledge
that students-- it says
the CIF ratings are incapable
of revealing certain things
about the quality
of the teaching.
Maybe the students
don't at this point
understand, exactly, what the
purpose of the course was,
or why a teacher did
things the way they did.
And so we like that they balance
peer faculty review with that.
Some things that were drawbacks.
We thought-- we didn't have
all the details of this survey.
So we don't know exactly
what was asked there.
Some of the implementation of
how this review takes place
was unclear to us.
And related to that,
some of these things
might be a little
unclear to faculty
how this is actually
taking place.
But we did like
that it is flexible,
dependent on departments,
and things like that.
Because each department
teaching area
may have different values
in a different environment.
So it's customizable to that.
I think this is another
one that has a lot of text.
And it's also a
fairly complex system.
And all of the documents
are in the Bitly.
Because there is quite a lot
to read on this particular one.
Thank you so much, to
the Notre Dame table.
So we're halfway through
our report-backs.
We have four more.
Table five had the
University of Texas.
Please go ahead.
Hi, there.
I'm Holly Gooding
from the Med School.
And we had a great
representation
from a lot of the
Harvard schools here.
So in some ways, I feel
like we had the kind
of classic end-of-course eval.
Which if you look up
there, you will see.
It's from the University
of Texas at Austin.
Some of the strengths
are that, right
in the beginning in the very
fine print that we suspect
students may not read, it
communicates the high stakes
of this for faculty.
It's really interesting.
People laugh, but I find
when I talk to students,
they often don't know that
their evaluation makes
a difference for promotion
and whether people
are invited back.
So it clearly communicates that
to the student, which is good.
It focuses on what
we thought were
some basic, but very important
things, like the organization,
and the clarity, and
fairness of the instructor.
So that's a strength.
Because you have to
have those things to get
to some of these higher level
things around curiosity,
and engagement, and motivation.
But that leads us to some
of the downsides, which
is that there's very
little about learning.
It's all about how the
instructor essentially
organized and
presented the material.
It's also overly long.
We were quite concerned
that students would tire out
and just put all fives,
all twos, all threes.
In terms of just
basic survey design,
in addition to its length,
there was no reverse coding.
So to make sure
students are really
reading, as opposed
to, again, just
doing all one or the other.
And yeah, just a lot of
concerns about the over
focus on the instructor's
organization,
and the length, and
concern about the validity
and reliability that
would come from that.
Well, thank you very much.
That issue of people
just marking all fives
came up in a couple
of our conversations.
Three more to look at.
The next one, the instrument
itself is the IDEA instrument.
And the example was
Stockton University's use
of this national instrument.
Hi.
I'm Daniel Jamous from academic
technology for the FAS.
So this is only the first page,
by the way, of the survey.
So it was really interesting.
We had a discussion about-- so
one of the drawbacks right off
the bat is the
comprehensiveness,
which is also a
strength you could say.
And the format.
It's a little
daunting to see this.
And again, there's a back page.
Lot of multiple choice.
But at the end, there are
a few open-ended questions.
However, when you
actually start to look
at the questions
and the content,
we felt for the most
part that it seemed
to hit all the right points.
Motivation of the students.
How the instructor
organized the class.
Emphasis on best practices,
teaching technique,
collaborative group, hands-on
teaching, use of technology.
And also focus on the personal
development of the student.
What was your motivation
for taking this class?
Did you reach your goal?
So our sense was that if you can
kind of overcome the initial,
maybe, fear of seeing this
SAT-like questionnaire,
then maybe you can actually get
some valuable information out
of it.
Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
Two more to go.
Table seven had the
University of Minnesota.
Hi.
So the form that we had
was a peer evaluation form.
We're assuming they also have
some sort of student evaluation
that takes place, right.
And Matt-- we had a
researcher on our team, too.
Matt kindly looked
up how this is used.
So it looks like it's part
of the tenure and promotion
process.
And they have this
evaluation that
happens pretty much
every year as part
of the evaluation of faculty.
So we thought that something
that really stood out
was that this
instrument really looks
like it measures-- so this is
the more quantitative part.
There are also two pages in
the beginning that are based
on a classroom observation.
And we thought that it was
a little bit concerning
that it's not really
set up in a way
to pair objective
evaluations of teaching along
with the interpretations
of those evaluations.
And that could lead to some--
what is it, political
interference
that someone brought
up earlier, possibly?
Or vague interpretations
of what the terms actually
mean being translated
into a positive
or a negative evaluation
that may not be justified.
We thought that the other
kind of problematic thing
about this instrument is that
it judges whether the faculty
member is following their
procedures or their protocols.
And it doesn't really
allow room for innovation
or for taking advantage
of something that might
be pedagogically very useful.
It's also not clear
whether this is
entirely respectful of faculty.
That was one of the concerns
that was brought up.
And how this is really used
in the tenure and promotion
process.
There really isn't
a lot of context
guiding this document
on the document itself.
Although there's a lot
of information online.
So maybe it is clear to
faculty who participation.
And yeah.
Overall, I think
our major concern
was that this seems much more
to evaluate process, rather
than actual learning outcomes.
And we'd ideally-- we think that
there are a lot of strengths.
But that was one of
our big concerns.
So that's interesting.
We're talking about improvising
versus being organized.
Right.
So our last table had
Dartmouth College.
And I think it was related
to specifically chemistry.
Some of these instruments
were for smaller subsets.
We should mention
that real quick.
Thanks.
So I'm Adam Beaver
from the Bok Center.
We had Dartmouth.
This evaluation is,
as you mentioned,
from a chemistry course.
I don't know if
it's more general.
It's also from a summer
course and from 2006.
So I don't know
if that remains--
if it remains the standard.
So things we noticed.
This is very close to Harvard's
Q Guide in a lot of ways.
I don't know whether that's
a strength or a drawback.
You can decide.
There were a few
things that we thought
were kind of pure
unalloyed strengths.
Most things, actually,
we put in both columns.
So for example, this is a
form that values very highly,
puts a strong emphasis
on student feedback
on the effectiveness
of teaching.
This gets at that question
of whether these things are
more like dining reviews,
in which everyone
is, by definition, an authority
on whether they enjoyed
their meal.
Or whether it's like a review
of a surgeon, in which case
you might not be an expert on
whether they are good surgeons.
So it's a strength and weakness
that it's asking students
not only about their experience,
but about whether they
think the teaching was
effective for them.
That's something that's
hard for students
to judge in the short term.
We liked very much
that it called
for a lot of critical
and qualitative feedback.
It's not all just
a Likert scale.
We liked question 10 that
compels students to do some--
perform some metacognition.
It's a question about--
sorry, I'm trying to
find it here on the form.
How did you contribute to
your own learning experience?
And the whole survey
actually starts with that.
It puts students back
into the experience
of their own learning
and asks them
what they brought to the course.
We think there could have
been more of that, though.
So that was a little bit in
the weakness category, too.
We thought there's a lot of
apples to oranges comparison
on the Likert scale.
So what would it mean, for
example, in question four,
I think it is there, to say,
I was engaged with the course
material.
I give it a three.
Doesn't that mean that
you're not actually engaged?
It's hard to measure that way.
It was hard to see--
there was a real jumble
of questions here
that might be of interest
to institutional research,
that you can imagine
the institution using,
and compiling, and analyzing.
But then a lot of questions
that seemed almost
to be aimed at the students'
ongoing metacognition, right.
Down the road, did you learn
anything from this course?
Thank you so much,
everybody, for playing along
with our two-minute limits.
I'm going to go
ahead and hand over
the microphone to
Kris, who's going
to walk us through the wrap-up.
Thank you, Anu.
So what we'd like you
to do now in our last
around 10, 12 minutes, is to
look at your worksheet again.
And just think for a minute
about the last two questions
now that you've had a
chance to listen and see
what everybody in the room did.
And just think about
what, if anything,
that you heard or
saw today might
be useful to bring or
adapt for use at Harvard?
And then what would
be some next steps?
And so we'll give you
a minute to think.
And then we're going to open it
up for our general discussion.
OK.
So we'd like to go ahead
and open up the floor.
If you have-- so what might
we do with this information
here at Harvard?
If you want to share,
just raise your hand
so Allison can bring you the
microphone for the videotape
for posterity.
Hi.
Deane Eastwood from the
School of Public Health.
We really like this exercise.
So we congratulate
you on the exercise.
It was very easy to take
someone else's instrument
and critique it.
And I think we're in the
process at the School of Public
Health-- and I know others are
looking at their instruments
and looking at the platforms.
So I think this is a
nice starting point,
that we could
critique a few others
and then take a look
at our own instruments.
And we might get
more out of that.
The process itself.
That was a tool to use.
Great.
Yeah, I thought the Minnesota
thing was pretty interesting.
I know that they've been
spending years there
figuring out how the faculty
help each other teach.
And I actually
understand that you
might think it's disrespectful.
But what if it had worked?
Then it would be amazing.
I guess the business
school does that already.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So I think, actually,
that's what we should do.
Because all these other things
look exactly like the Q Guide.
We could add a few
things here or there.
Nothing's very different.
Well, nothing's 20% different.
Deena.
So two points.
First one, based on the Stanford
instrument that we examined,
I found it refreshing to
be able to offer faculty
the opportunity
to have some input
and customize the questionnaire.
I feel like it has
a lot of benefits,
not without their drawbacks.
And the second, which
relates to the Minnesota
evaluation and the
North Carolina State,
is the notion that--
have a clear articulation
for which stakeholders
have which input into
the process of evaluating
teaching and learning.
I'm not sure that I, myself,
have thought as much about this
as I think it deserves
to be thought.
And I love the analogy of the
surgeon reviews and the dining
reviews.
So thank you.
I had a reaction to this.
I'm the Dean of the
Extension School.
And it came from,
what will we actually
do with the information?
And my reaction was, I really
like the Stanford instrument.
Because it's simple.
And you're likely to
get honest feedback.
And it'll probably be
directionally corrective.
And you can parse that.
And where you have
problems, you can
take that small
subset of students,
know who was in the class, and
do a more comprehensive survey.
Or maybe you give them
some more incentive
to get you detail to truly
diagnose the challenges
and come up with a repair.
So I was putting that
practical overlay.
I would love to have all the
information Texas at Austin
said.
We counted like 175 questions.
It isn't going to happen.
Not with human beings taking it.
But that's why I kind of
like the Stanford approach.
A simple entry and then
a plan to follow up when
you saw something interesting.
Yeah, so I really enjoyed seeing
the Minnesota, the 360 feedback
models that have
ways that we could
create kind of
communities of practice
among faculty and
other instructors.
On the question of how
we could do this here,
Harvard is the
kind of place that
often avoids experimentation
and iteration
if it can't rollout the
perfect 100% solution, I think.
Probably all large
institutions are like that.
It would be nice
to think about ways
that you could pilot
some of these initiatives
on a small scale.
To take something like a
portion of the curriculum,
maybe the Gen Ed
curriculum or something,
and think about
ways that, at least
in that subdivision
of the university,
we could try doing some things
like creating these community
360 evaluations,
even if we don't yet
know if it's the right thing to
do for thousands upon thousands
of students and courses.
Thank you.
So that kind of next
step part of it.
One of the things that
several people have commented,
and I completely agree,
that having the opportunity
to change or insert things
into some of the questions,
as was the case at
Stanford, is great.
I'd like to see whatever
appropriate level--
could be a department,
could be a school--
a discussion of what
those questions might be.
Because I think
many of the faculty
might have actually rather
radically different examples,
even if they're teaching
multiple sections
of same course.
And that discussion
by itself can
be quite helpful
in getting people
to reflect on their teaching.
Same table we have.
I might just add to that before
passing it over to Dustin,
that we've included as many URLs
as we could in this material.
And it definitely is worth
browsing around in those.
Because especially Stanford
has an incredibly robust set
of tools and resources
around the design
of learning outcomes, and the
flexibility and the creativity
involved in that.
So each of these schools--
this is kind of the
tip of an iceberg
resting on top of a lot
of institutional work
that bears further look.
Hi.
Dustin Tingley.
This was very helpful.
Thank you.
I was kind of surprised-- and
maybe you found this in some
of your research in this space--
about the lack of emphasis
on longitudinal data.
So for example, a systematic
university-wide mid-term
evaluation of courses.
It doesn't have to be as long
or as complicated or anything.
Because otherwise
we're sort of-- you're
getting the averages,
but you don't know
what you were starting with.
And so a midterm evaluation is
at least one way to do that.
And there are further
good pedagogic reasons
to do that anyways.
But I guess I'm not aware of any
school that is systematically
doing that across
all its classes.
And I've got to wonder why.
Our teaching and
learning centers
tell us we should be doing that.
We get templates
on how to do it.
But we don't have a systematic
investment to do it.
And so I'm just kind of curious.
That raises a similar
thing that just came up.
You know, I found out--
I guess it's an HBS question.
But actually eliciting prior
knowledge from students.
Like, you know, how much
prior knowledge did you have?
It has that similar
flavor of you're
trying to have something
about the longitudinal sort
of direction of a student.
So anyways, I think that,
at the end of the day,
that's where the investment
might very well be.
Yeah, I mean, I
think my experience
teaching a number of
different institutions,
I've never had any sort of
formalized, systematized
mid-term evaluations.
They encourage you to
do things like that.
And I don't think
we covered anything
like that in any
of the documents?
Do you--
We weren't looking-- because
we were looking at summative--
you know, to be used for
promotion and tenure than--
I think the one advantage
of the national instruments
is that they have that
kind of a data set.
So with the IDEA,
you can look semester
by semester at a
department's courses.
And because it's a
national data set,
you can also see comparisons
across peer institutions.
So I think that's the
trade-off between a homegrown
and a national instrument.
The national instrument gives
you that larger infrastructure.
They also tend to be the ones
with many, many questions,
probably for the same reason.
So one of the things
that was a little
controversial at the
University of Pennsylvania
is that they had--
the students had done
a longitudinal analysis
by professor over a decade.
So the danger of having
the data accessible
is all the different ways
you could slice and dice it.
So we are pretty close to time.
And we don't want to run over.
So first of all,
I would like to,
on behalf of my
co-facilitators, thank you
all very much for coming,
for doing the work
that you didn't know you
were signing up for when
you signed up for this session.
We're glad to hear that
you found it valuable.
Again, we do have all of the
materials and more online.
So please feel free to download,
peruse, pick at, dissect,
adapt.
We were very fortunate in being
able to find a lot of materials
from these institutions.
And the last thing
that we wanted
to leave you with
and take with you
is, on the back
of your worksheet,
you'll notice a
set of principles,
again from Stanford,
that we thought
would be a nice way of
just, as a parting thought
and to tie in with
the theme of the rest
of the HILT conference of--
what are the-- are there
underlying principles
at Harvard that
we could all agree
on that would help
us guide our teaching
evaluation, in whatever
form that might be,
in whichever schools and
departments we're in?
So we just wanted to sort
of leave you with this idea.
And I think it echoes
what a lot of you said,
that while we clearly
think evaluating teaching
is important, that no one
method offers a complete view
of that quality.
And so how can we arrive
at a set of methods
and a set of principles that
help us measure what we believe
is important to us?
So we want to let you get
on to your next session.
Thank you all very much
for your participation.